mettons d'abord les choses au point il
s'agit d'un journal de bord pas d'un
journal intime demain c'est mon premier
jour au collège heureusement je suis pas
tout seul au collège il y a mon meilleur
ami Robert
voilà ce que tu dois savoir fais
attention tu t'assois le premier jour
n'utilises jamais les toilettes du
deuxième étage surtout fais attention de
ne pas attraper la marque du fromage
parce que sinon c'est comme si t'étais
mort merci beaucoup Rodrigue pour ces
merveilleux concerts
tout va bien se passer au collège je
vais demander à faire l'école à la
maison
y on se rejoint chez moi pour jouer
jouer jouer jouer
je pense qu'après ça j'aurais besoin
d'une bonne thérapie
on est au collège maintenant tu crois
pas qu'on devrait se comporter comme des
garçons de notre âge
mon grain de beauté secret mais cette
soirée m'a traumatisé pour toujours
regardez-moi ces petits clowns il trône
dehors au lieu de dormir avec pas le
droit
[Musique]
la vache maman un jour je serai riche et
célèbre mais pour l'instant je suis
coincé au collège entouré d'idiot
tu restes avec moi tout ira bien pour
toi
[Musique]
oh zut désolé j'avais pas vu que c'était
vous les garçons vous allez bien
vous allez bien
[Musique]